Justin Bieber visibly disheveled shortly
after news broke that his ex Selena
Gomez was hospitalized the 24 year old
pop star was seen attending midweek
church service at Hillsong LA Wednesday
night without his wife Haley Baldwin
after service Justin returned to his car
with a group of friends who appeared to
comfort him during an emotional exchange
here's the Biebs hugging his pal before
shielding his face from cameras and
driving off it's unusual for the sorry
singer to attend church without Haley
the pair has regularly been spotted at
the church together since they rekindled
their romance though just hours before
the paparazzi pics were taken the 21
year old model shared this sweet kissing
photo with her man on Instagram while
the duo has yet to have a big wedding a
source tells ET Justin and Haley are
legally married it's an amazing feeling
pressure as for Selena a source tells ET
she's getting treatment at a mental
health facility
another source telling ET quote selena
has dealt with depression for a while
and her and the people around her have
always kept an eye on how she feels even
more so since her kidney transplant 20
years he's the kidney transplant how are
both of you guys doing great yeah we're
both living our lives we're both super
healthy it's like oh it's been a year
just weeks before Selena checked herself
in she announced she was taking a break
from social media writing I am equally
grateful to be able to step back and
live my life present to the moment I
have been given I like to choose to live
my life in a way where I want to be wait
free and I know that's impossible to do
because I have a million on me right now
but I and everybody does but I think it
is important to kind of go through your
life the way you want and I like to come
at things with my best